tonight hey Chef Chef Ramsay heads to
Arizona and visits one of the cleanest
restaurants in Kitchen Nightmares
history this is a joke but soon after
meeting the husband and wife team Sammy
and Amy he uncovers a number of problems
you [__] you all
that you can come
and kind of things oh my gosh
Sammy who runs the front of the house is
completely disorganized I can't I can't
I cannot work I can't Amy runs the
kitchen but refuses to listen to anyone
these are still bought crap frozen
ravioli crap and they're delicious oh
it's not surprising that there is such a
high turnover of Staff Katie I quit and
at this restaurant the customer is never
right you [__] yourself out you
[__] get ready to witness a
colossal uphill battle if you're that's
a [__] you're good as Chef Ramsay
faces off against two defiant owners
Pizza is undercooked that's not true
this may be the one restaurant I don't
even know why we came back here I'm
going home now you're going home that
Chef Ramsay has no choice but to walk
away I am finished all my stuff is going
back where it belongs and that's it
what is that you serving rotten fruit
kill them then wake up you wake up shut
the plate down here that is amazing
thank you
Scottsdale Arizona an upscale Phoenix
suburb
it's also home to Amy's Baking Company
opened in 2006 by husband and wife team
Sammy and Amy busoglow
it was at a very early age that I
discovered I had a
had a true passion and talent for
anything having to do with the culinary
arts just give me the personal darling
if you can alright alright so in 2006
Sammy invested over a million dollars
into this restaurant to make my dream
come true
we are ready okay but we're in the
restaurant business it's not all daisies
and ponies and unicorns I understand
this whole substitution thing
approximately two years ago these
reviewers and these bloggers decided to
make up lies and say that they ate the
food and it was disgusting
[__] and we lost a tremendous amount of
business because of it they're just
[__] haters
really just anything good I'll take it
there's a lot of things that are wrong
with the food that she just doesn't
realize too garlicky too buttery too
sweet not cooked enough too overdone
that doesn't work for me
if someone has criticism Sammy tells
them you don't know what the food is
supposed to taste like even you don't
know
what is wrong with it if anyone tell me
that my wife's food is not good I just
tell him to leave the restaurant I don't
want them and don't come back it's your
first time and last time don't come back
madam not only do they lash out and
swear at customers I will go tell them
to [__] off if my husband doesn't but
they take it one step further and
retaliate against them I hope he eats it
and I just made it really spicy for him
the customer is not always right choose
another pizza or nothing and I'm not
here to take [__] from anybody I'm not
20 we have people make [__] up that
isn't true I'm not doing it
really hurt somebody if they send back
my cake one second she's like a nice
little care bear thank you so much I
love you you're such a good girl and the
next second she's at Cruella Deville I'm
stopping all the food
no why it has to go to the freaking
trash are you kidding me right now
unfortunately the majority of the people
in Arizona think that if you come to our
restaurant that we're gonna yell at you
scream at you and throw you outside and
that is not who we are keep walking
Mister you just keep walking Chef
Francis is coming to tell the people how
the food is good here you can go Madam
don't come back Madam I'll be happy not
to see you here thank you I think Chef
Angie is going to be wasting his time he
can't change Sammy name they're lost
cause
change it
we are ready okay good evening do you
guys know what you want three cheese and
tomato sauce all right thank you you're
welcome Miranda may be the only server
on staff I can't do the computer so he's
the only one that has control over that
but she is not allowed to input orders
poor wine or handle money the ravioli
and then they want the pizza the only
one who can do that is Sammy okay okay
just move move I know Sammy thinks that
he's doing everything all by himself
but Sammy doesn't realize he's actually
messing everything up I need another
wine I can't I can't I cannot work I
can't
Sammy
look all the orders I have what do you
want because
he had like 30 tickets in his hand I
think with Amy only cooking one ticket
at a time we're not making any of this
until I get to that ticket the diners
are in for a long wait I've never waited
but the one table that has received
their food is unsatisfied what is the
problem
okay if you came to eat to enjoy then
you should know what you like to eat sir
certainly you don't know what you like
to eat I guess not okay Amy what can you
make me pear salad instead of that
scissor seriously don't worry I told him
to [__] off
yelling maybe they don't understand it
doesn't come from a can kidding me right
now
what they say it's not cooked enough to
be to be
the food we're making is going straight
to the trash and there are starving
people that could be eating it but
instead these people decide that they're
going to come [__] with my life
you guys are full of [__] yeah
I've never got our pizza I never got
this
stop it they're living I don't care
stop it stop what it's in the oven
send them home
it's coming you want to wait you wait
you don't want to pay what did you
happen you [__] up from you you
understand Sammy do you understand you
don't [__] yourself count you
[__]
I'm not [__] kidding yeah
what does it mean I'm in the office
don't call the foolish you're crazy
where's the pizza in the oven
I told you you go [__] you [__] you
kidding me right now I'm kidding and
[__] you no kidding yes [__] you take
the money no I want the money from him I
am calling
back I know but hey you're not touching
him get away [__] you are you
piece of [__] you are a little pansies
[__] you
give me a break this is you guys I make
excellent food
you [__] you all think that you
can come in here and say these things
are you kidding me this is ridiculous
I've never seen anything like this
with very little knowledge of the
previous night's dinner service
Chef Ramsay arrives looking to find out
why Amy's Baking Company needs his help
desserts
hey Chef how are you how are you doing
nice to see you first name is Sammy
Sammy I'm the owner yes wow oh look at
that come on my wife Amy yeah uh can I
meet this lady yes no please yeah let me
yes Gotham Ramsey want to meet you he
wants to know who is the chef of wood
that all those beautiful uh come around
come around so nice to meet you I'll
give him a hug
uh did you make them yes I did uh
incredible likewise good to see you I
mean they're extraordinary thank you
that's very nice it means a lot coming
from you I knew that still bought no the
restaurant is beautiful thank you and I
want you to see my kitchen after or
before this I want and then you tell me
about our kitchen also rice show me the
kitchen okay
oh my God yes I
I'm the lucky one he is my soulmate and
we're in this business together and we
stand strong together we have to because
there's a lot of online bullies and
haters and bloggers we stand up to them
and I think we're the only ones that
ever have as restaurant owners and they
come and they try to attack us and say
horrible things that are not true
because they're they're used to eating
processed wood chips or used to getting
things for free and not from us okay
um let's catch up with the haters I know
that stuff I have a quick look at the
kitchen of course uh normally owners
don't like it when I expect kitchens but
they're full shiny it's like a
basketball court if you're not a good
one you know the jacket you don't need
it it's like a doctor's surgery in here
yes thank you thank you thank you for
saying the truth oh my goodness me this
is a joke I mean look dates labels
everything sectioned off wow what a
pleasure
are you the sushi Chef she is yes this
goes through the dining room okay
the restaurant itself is very clean and
nice but it's Amy and Sammy that are the
problem do not judge a book by its cover
so take me back to the beginning how
long will we be married almost 10 years
old we got married five months after we
met
wow well I prayed for him and God sent
him to me and I wasn't going to waste
any time
she said forget you you Sammy Hoffner
enough it was a Playboy you were a
Playboy in Vegas he was serious he was
even Hugh Hefner who didn't have as
beautiful women as we did all the
Playmates would come to our table it was
a player but with me it didn't work like
that I am individual or nothing at all
you got married that was everything out
wow so um were you trained in the
industry
I'm developer I build I build custom
houses but when the crisis started I say
I still have money what you want me to
do with it she played me she said my
dream he was to open a restaurant I just
throughout my life had a passion and a
god-given talent for it and this is all
I want to do
thank you as well thank you that's
beautiful
I'm the only one that makes them and if
I'm not here or working we're not open
say that again if I am not here if my
husband's not here
we don't run without each other here
you're kidding me no that's no way to
run a business we can't find Qualified
people to work they want to come and get
a paycheck Arizona
I enjoyed a lot of them this is we know
that big is worried is my biggest
problem in my life but I cannot find
people I can count on them I can trust
them dirty they're lazy how many people
have you been through Allah a few
hundreds a few hundreds yeah so other
than an issue with staff what's wrong
with this bloody restaurant I have
issues with customers that are trying to
be online bullies and say horrible
things online bullets they're online
bullies and write things that are not
true if they write that I have
store-bought dough they write that
things are frozen I understand that but
those things are not true but when did
this start
this guy came in that started this
entire online bullying he ordered pizza
margarita and after I say okay how is
your pizza I say it's a frozen pizza the
next day you went and give us a review
oh my God my wife she was well
retaliated you wrote back to him oh yeah
right why I told him I thought he was a
loser he was a [__]
I'm not going to let anybody bully me
bully my husband that's a joke
you need thick skin in this business
well they can't they called me crazy Amy
B because I stood up to them and I need
people who respect you who know that you
have earned your stripes in the kitchen
and in life I need them to listen to you
and not the online bullies and take your
word that you're saying that our food is
good I mean if all your food is as good
as it deserves trust me there's
something not quite right here thank you
were you a control freak I am
worse what a combination we have to
clone us
is that possible
Right do you have children well we have
three little boys but they're trapped
inside cat bodies
our babies are cats they're my whole
life besides my husband and my business
I speak feline wow
meeting YouTube for the first time you
are both [__] nuts I know I'm gonna
have a little sample of the menu okay do
your thing normally I will
good is this feeling Sammy in front of
my house it's pretty much just me how
long have you been here a month and a
half good tips I don't make tips
that again I make hourly serious you
must be the only server in this country
I know that doesn't get tipped out so
where do the tips go the owner
yeah I can't believe that I know I try
to tell him
wow okay great thank you you're welcome
[Music]
we spoke earlier about the problem with
staff yeah I just found out something
pretty major Miranda the young girl yeah
you go give her her tips no
Sammy he cannot take service tips then
bring me the people who's going to do
their job and I don't have to interfere
they can take the whole tips for them
did you see I already took three orders
by myself and send them already today
you're the owner I'm doing the most of
the job wow I'm ready to order okay do
you know already what you like yesterday
yeah the Fig and pair prosciutto pizza
please yeah and then I'm gonna go for a
blue ribbon Burger medium medium rare
excellent please and I'll take the
salmon burger as well the same time
and then I'll fancy some gnocchi get all
the pastas homemade right it is but not
the gnocchi today it's not Ahmed we
didn't have time to make them okay I'll
go straight to the very earlier okay
which one do you like the red pepper
perfect thank you you're welcome
the story is becoming a little clearer
[Music]
okay Amy yeah this is the chef's order
okay I believe that once Chef Ramsay
tastes my food as a chef he'll be able
to tell that this is what God wants me
to do
[Music]
Miranda what is that doorbell on the
side of the wall for whenever we have
dirty dishes we ring it and then the
Buster comes and grabs the dishes from
there why would you walk around to put
the plates in the pot was
the first time in my career a pot washer
has a doorbell
[Music]
oh ding dong
right three cheese pizza ah the cheese
pizza
[Music]
it's nobody's I'm the only one who use
it
yeah but the quicker you teach it the
quicker you can take it back and see it
I was teacher when you come the time I
will teach you Miranda have you ever
worked in a POS system yes at every job
that I've worked at every job and how
many jobs have you had before you worked
ABC a lot a lot she doesn't need
training she knows how to do it thank
you
thank you I'll get you
the freaking pair and crochet Pizza
well the crust is supposed to be good
but it's not that crusty
very very sweet
after all this weight wow that is so
sweet but that's not the issue the issue
is the dough is raw I feel like it's raw
it's doughy
I don't know how we come out today like
this but normally they love that pizza
it's really really lovely I'm telling
you what I'm getting and it's raw soggy
and wet and too sweet in general
please thank you oh my God I don't
forget about it
what's wrong nothing I feel like Sammy
sugar coats a lot of what happens in the
restaurant so Amy gets this feeling that
like everything she's doing is correct
everything's right don't worry don't
worry everything is okay I'm not worried
I'm afraid he's going to say something
isn't good
I know my wife she doesn't take the
criticism she will be shaking and then
she said that's it I'm leaving just I'll
tell you all about it after after this
the product and do like you do normally
just do it
oh my God I'm going to freak out
Chef Ramsay has been sitting at the
table for well over an hour I think it's
raw and so far all that he has sampled
is an undercooked Pizza I don't even
tell her you didn't like the uh the pity
[Music]
you didn't even tell the difference yet
I know my wife she's getting nervous
telling you the truth do you want the
teller come with me I just wanted to
know yeah
anyway I am 75 minutes in and so far
I've had a undercooked Pizza I know
you've been waiting I'm gonna start
eating my ticket okay I'm going to tell
her you're starving I'm going to let you
are starving okay she'll move okay
she'll move
do you know where that goes yes
okay
thank you wow
blue cheese
mushrooms marinades garlic aioli
white truffle oil
and crispy bacon bits and a soggy bun
that's just full of grease geez come on
I have a lot of nerve calling this a
blue ribbon Burger
[Music]
well medium round it's not
just a mess
oh dear
that is over complicated so unnecessary
and look
there's one [__] Burger
yeah the bun what a mess okay
really disappointing I am starving
I got it thank you this is for him Yes
red pepper ravioli
red pepperoni there you go
the salmon burger doing I'll go check on
that okay
he wanted to know how long on the salmon
burger it's on its way you don't need to
keep reminding us we know okay I was
just saying I know but you don't need to
come tell us we know that it needs to go
out
smells weird
oh here's my summer Burger wow thank you
though you're welcome oh gosh
sweet and spicy
[Music]
all right
miss it has to be one of the most
confused ravioli dishes I've ever seen
and tasted in my entire life
wow
it doesn't make sense doesn't make sense
huh sweet and spicy yeah really early
with bacon and sweet corn Chopped with
cilantro are these store-bought yes he
told me that this is
thank you
look at this thing here
this is what I've been waiting for
it's like a salmon cake crab cake
Burger
it's overcooked I mean it's it's not
good although it may be good for those
three boys
a few cats at home can we take that
please because it is like eating dry cat
food do you want to take a sample no
they really don't
come on meow meow
Amy
yes that was a lot longer than I
expected and you know there were some
big bumps in that meal um what kind of
bumps what didn't you like let's go
through it later okay okay I'm gonna go
get changed okay and I want to see how
this place functions and then after
service cover all the points you look
disappointed I am disappointed okay but
let's get through this like okay yeah
okay
okay thank you
that's for you oh thank you thank you
okay
[Music]
please do me a favor you can they are
good
[Music]
okay listen we're gonna start to get
ready you guys we're gonna open
how does the line work who does what
Christine does mostly the salads and I
do the pizzas I have people tell me it's
the best pizza that they've ever had in
their life my pizza today was
undercooked so it was raw and I said we
take that back he said I can't daughter
in service why is that you're your
husband and wife yeah yeah it's not as
if you're sort of manager and assistant
manager so why can't you go and tell
your wife of course sweetheart Pizza
[__] wake up it's undercooked I don't
think your pizza was undercooked I
checked it when I took it out of the
oven just like can I do every other
pizza and to me it was crispy on the
bottom when I cut it it was crunchy so
to me it wasn't okay so that's your
version because you didn't see her come
back however the bun for the beef burger
was soggy as anything blue cheese
marinated mushrooms crispy bacon bits
white truffle oil you comes up with
those ideas I did because there's
certain things that don't go together
and that's for them Chef Ramsay is
standing there riding my ass about white
truffle oil and garlic aioli oh my God
like he's never heard of any flavor
profile in the world it's disgusting I
have never had a problem with that
hamburger ever
because your husband doesn't tell you
and the the salmon burger was like a
salmon fish cake in between a dry bun
but it was a dry bun or it was a soggy
bun that was dry dry Pate dry it's good
like that we have people tell us all the
time
there's no point in me saying anything
to you because you just don't where it's
good like that whatever
the uh raviors be cooking from Frozen
yes we do you know you can make these
better what yes I can make them from
scratch take them off oh yes of course
why don't I just delete everything from
my menu and then close my doors what do
you want me to sell these are
store-bought trap Frozen raviolis and
they're delicious and I the first time
I've ever okay did you taste it you
didn't taste that one I think you're
gonna get the feedback I said they were
disgusting people usually love it I've
never had a problem with it but I
usually love it yes real customers not
haters oh come on Amy raviolis that are
in the freezer oh my God sacrilegious
ladies and gentlemen two seconds please
the owner is trying to pull the wall
over your eyes by offering you frozen
raviolis that aren't even made within
500 miles of this front door so would
you mind personally if I 86 them to stop
you from eating crab
really early okay I have too much
respect for your customers to [__]
them now when you tell your wife or
shall I
it's dinner service and Amy continues to
deflect everything the owner is trying
to pull the wall over your eyes by
offering you frozen raviolis so to make
his point Chef Ramsay decides to do a
little research with the customers would
you mind if I 86 them I know that's
right are you going to tell your wife or
shall I I will tell her thank you okay
listen yeah no more raviolis and no more
hamburgers and no more salmon burgers
people can only have cakes tonight okay
okay I'm good with that
complete [__]
she can't take criticism why is that ask
her that question I have the same
problem for that
are we used to waiting on something yeah
yeah
is that coming can you look on B4 and
see what else they had they should have
pasta recipe nope I don't have it I
didn't give it to me
Sammy Sammy I did write it down for you
it's right there what is it Pasta
Rustica it's okay
are you sure you don't need to question
me Katie you can go home right now
sorry Sammy I would appreciate it if you
would send Katie home right now I don't
need an attitude from her she comes in
her it's because there's the two others
oh my God am I sure
what a little [__]
I mean I'm not gonna talk to you right
now because I have to talk to him I will
there's no point in talking to you
thank you
and the pizza food is leaving the
kitchen at a snail's pace
and it doesn't appear to be worth the
wait you can take this back too you
didn't like it okay
[Music]
do they tell you no every single time a
customer doesn't lick their plate the
waitress doesn't come to tell me that
Amy no one's licking that just ignore
him I am ignoring everything that's
happening stop thank you excuse me
sir
that just comes back to the table and it
goes straight into the pot wash then
they didn't like it so if they didn't
like it what are we gonna do about it
let's wait we finish today the kitchen
needs to know okay then I'm going to
tell her thank you okay Amy this is the
summit
they didn't like it for me this is all
[__] none of you've known about this
because the young girl Maria grabbed the
plane was about to throw it away that's
a Common Thread in this restaurant
there's no point in me speaking so I'm
just gonna work
it's like one long nightmare wow ten
dollar tip yeah it's nice for you
because yeah why not do you think the
girls deserve some tips tonight no they
get hourly and so do you think if I went
and asked every customer when I leave a
tip that'll go straight to the owner and
not to the server do you think they'd be
astounded let me ask that table there
sir the tip that you left the young lady
server the owner takes the tips
don't [__] with me yeah I will [__] with
you what the [__] you think you are
God Sammy's going to hurt him I'm fed up
I'm getting sick and tired of your
[__] but then [__] answer my
question then [__] answer my question
tell the customers they're gonna get
their tips no they don't they should be
told that you're taking them because
this service deserve them you want to
speak with me
then I will [__] with you oh my God
everybody got this food yeah we're close
we're closing the kitchen
I think Katie you can go
for sure I'm talking to you Katie okay
Katie listen to me when I'm speaking to
you do not walk away from me you don't
work here anymore okay don't start don't
start crying
oh my God
she comes to the kitchen tonight she's
like I set a table she said are you sure
it's okay please no no no come on she
doesn't work here anymore she's a
poisonous little Viper and I don't allow
people to have an attitude in my
restaurant what does she know who the
hell is she she is gone that's who she
is don't let the door hit you on the way
out
tonight Chef Ramsay witnessed how
dysfunctional Amy and Sammy are at
running their business Katie you do not
work here anymore okay including firing
Katie for simply asking a question
[Music]
five young girl
take a big deep breath and see if you
can get some form of resolution here
okay
believe it or not my intentions are good
you're shaking your head already I'm
listening
it's become evident that you can't take
criticism
why is that are you seriously asking me
yeah I am don't have to cry I don't want
you to cry you don't have to cry I'm not
going to try something I'm trying to
speak and take out my
my conversation No One lets me
ever not nobody oh my God I know that
but you're
what I do normally is good I don't have
people sending things back to me
Amy you're saying that you don't know
because food comes back it goes straight
to the dishwashing that's what the whole
issue is you've been avoiding everything
behind your back are the most amazing
desserts and in your freezer is still
bought [__] raviolis that you're never
gonna convince me or a customer that
they're good the sauce is delicious the
raviolis we think that they're very good
what I'm struggling with is that you
convince yourselves that it's rice
it's not
tomorrow I want you open minded okay
you as well Sammy
make promises that I know I can't keep
I'm going to do everything within myself
to try all you're getting from me is the
truth
right now that's what you need good
night good night
[Music]
after one of the most difficult days he
has ever had on Kitchen Nightmares Chef
Ramsay's arrived with a plan to start
turning around Amy's Baking Company
but with Amy and Sammy not at the
restaurant
he takes the time to meet with former
staff members that have reached out to
him morning morning how are you both
good Jessica good to see you Henry Henry
nice to see you first of all
Jessica what was your job I was
hired as a food Runner Sammy told me
that he didn't like people who went to
culinary school because he didn't think
that we knew anything and when I started
I was only allowed to pour water glasses
and set them at the table so I worked
out front for a few months and basically
had to beg my way back into the kitchen
I'm Henry that was a buster for the most
part how long ago were you there a
little over a month and what kind of
things did you see that I remember he
was always in a bad mood no matter what
like I've never seen him in like a good
mood he can't take complaints in like a
professional manner which is the worst
part he made me wash his car one day
what that was the most ridiculous thing
I've ever done for him they were always
yelling at each other
in the year and a half I was there I saw
at least 50 people come and go 50. they
were in and out so fast wow what happens
when customers complain about their food
they get told that they're wrong that
you know no we have the best food in the
country you're wrong like there have
been times people have gotten salmon
that's raw and they'll send it back
saying you know can you cook this a
little more and they're like you don't
know how to eat food you don't know what
you're doing this is perfect you just
you obviously don't know
customers always wrong there I was
insane it's just that they don't really
know how to manage a restaurant I don't
know what it is but they both think that
like the whole world is out to get them
listen I appreciate the feedback
you've been very helpful and appreciate
the honest truth absolutely uh wish me
good luck I need it good luck but we can
help you thank you
wow it gets worse
[Music]
morning
good morning morning
today is a new day yeah I hope so you're
not very happy now
um never had this experience like this
it's disaster I've never had experience
like this either
we want to clarify a few things please
should we sit down so there's no
animosity sit down let's clarify a few
things
what would you like to clarify
[Music]
what I have a problem with were the
comments you were saying to me last
night while I was trying to focus on the
food let's look at one thing at a time
and be open and honest okay okay
for me this was about uncovering the
truth when I'm told that the river is a
freshly made can I finish sorry when
your husband told me that the road
movies were fresh I ordered them and the
rivalries were disgusting and not fresh
and if you're gonna try and continue to
pull all over customers Eyes by sending
them fake fresh made raviolis they need
to know since my alarm Bells go as big
now you may want to sit there and argue
but you're not prepared to understand
that I'm here to show you what's right
and you can't take that I can I'm ready
for that I have no problems with
I told you about the burger you choose
to listen I do not every time I tell you
something with it you come back with an
excuse I kept asking you what's wrong I
told you the bun for the beef burger was
soggy as anything I have never had a
problem with that hamburger ever
you said the salmon burger was dry but
it was wet is it dry or is it wet which
one is it one outside no you you're
confused I'm not confused when we're
talking about food
the way you screamed at that young girl
last night would you let anybody come
into your restaurant in your kitchen and
speak to you the way that that kid spoke
to me last night would you do you think
we're gonna let someone hold a gun to
our head and we're going to give them
our ass and let them do anything they
want from us all she asks is no she did
it with an attitude a serious attitude
she's like are you sure
for me are you sure you don't need to
question me Katie you can go home right
now no she didn't okay now you're over
exaggerating again all right but you'll
claim her you'll blame the customer but
customers were waiting for the food
through your husband's mistake but okay
we're going to forget this today right
we're going to start if we continue the
show we're going to start from scratch
this is not a show for me this is a
restaurant that is in crisis with a
delusional owner that can't take
criticism so I'm going to tell you as it
is
I met Jessica and Henry this morning and
I got told some awful things like what
the way you treat stuff
they have to clean cars in the middle of
service because the boss wants his car
cleaned
and then witnessing over 50 staff being
fired in that short period of time
really 50 staff 50 staff you're saying
that I have fired 50 staff since just
you're saying I am
proof that's because you're saying have
you not had a turnover of more than 50
people
because she was wrong 100 or even more
than 100 yeah not only 50. yeah actually
worse than she told me
yes it's worse yes could you tell your
wife that because I don't know if she
knows I need a drink of water excuse me
water
because Christ are you gonna attack me
for wanting to [__] [__] drink some
water to my God I don't even know why
why we came back here I'm going home
[Music]
this morning Chef Ramsay arrived with a
plan on how to turn around the
restaurant but the owners wanted to
clear up a few matters now you may want
to sit there and argue but you're not
prepared to understand but I'm here to
show you what's right Unfortunately they
are still not prepared to listen to what
Chef Ramsay has to say
again yesterday I didn't even eat drink
or eat or drink and I have to drink
water Jesus Christ are you gonna attack
me for wanting to [__] drink some
water to my God I don't even know why we
came back here I'm going home now you're
going home this is such [__] nobody
even [__] is listening to me [__]
they're gonna go buy Jessica this
unbelievable these people are incredible
and I've had enough and come here to be
abused my own restaurant I want to go
home
[Music]
because I'm insulted you verbally
insulted me yesterday and I held my
tongue out of class I didn't tell you
the truth I didn't say nasty things to
you okay really I didn't really when I
told you about the burger you refused to
listen you don't understand you're
judging me on coming in here disrupting
me
doing this disrupting you did disrupt us
last night how could I focus on my lunch
when you're standing here what about
what I could for you who distracted you
then everybody what are you talking
about blaming everybody again I do my
best so our business doesn't close
because we can't find Qualified people
you go get Miranda and that little Katie
and Jessica bring them here and let me
see how they work where you do that of
course oh do you know what they're
scared of you but unfortunately you
convince yourself in your little Amy's
world that everything you cook touch
scent it's perfect I do not what are you
in my arms he goes well with white
truffle well let me show you something
can I show you reviews hundreds of
reviews that are excellent right there
no good reviews real customers that have
supported us
you're attacking my business and my life
this is all I do is live this life every
day you're not telling me the problem is
you are saying I'm delusional I'm in
this I'm this I'm this
can we talk about what we came here to
speak about please
I am always about the problems that
you've had that you cannot talk to your
wife and the issues that she can't take
criticism
that's fine
I think you're too far gone okay then
let's end the show you think I'm too far
gone there's no hope yala yala it's
Christmas let's go home
okay
I can't help people
can't help themselves and cannot
ever
take one ounce
of criticism
and if you're not willing to change
I'm not gonna butt heads argue scream
whatever you want to say
but this is not normal
and it's not normal for a restaurant to
go through that many staff it's not
normal for a kitchen that's small to
have 65 items on the menu and it's not
normal
for the level of animosity that you've
built inside this restaurant and outside
you have the right to run the business
the way you want to run your business
I have the right
to do the right thing
and the right thing for me is to get out
of here
good luck
[Music]
wow
participate in this [__]
give me a break
can I take this thing with me we don't
need his help maybe he knows that it all
has to come down
and now he's gone he walked away he'll
go on with his life Sammy and I will go
on with our life
[Music]
the 100 Kitchen Nightmares I've met two
owners who I could not help and it
wasn't because I didn't want to it was
because they are incapable of listening
and in a short period of time they've
managed to piss off the community and go
through over 100 employees in one year
Sammy and Amy continue to blame everyone
else yet their biggest problem is
themselves and I know
whatever changes I would have made they
are never going to stick to them and
that's why I've decided to do something
I've never done before it's such a shame
[Music]
foreign